holy oak legs honey yeah Kleenex oh it's
for everyone in my entire life I've
dealt with body image and my self-esteem
I'm always constantly worried about what
I look like drag queen seems so
confident their personalities shine
that's how I want to be and we bring
what we've experienced to the table
because we're not therapists for not
adopters
we're not here to diagnose anybody but
we're here to show you what we've gone
through and how we can help you through
our personal walks of life I was gonna
say it's a reality show but it's weird
is not scripted oh this is not the dress
for 30,000 I don't feel pretty I don't
feel like a coin ooh we have what to do
drag nificent has the Queen's helping
others find their inner Queens one epic
makeover at the time whether it be
someone looking to revamp their look
after a dramatic weight loss for someone
getting set for a high school reunion
this is the most beautiful at elver
field in my entire life
so watch this butterfly boom I am so
proud of her drag nificent first episode
will have the ladies helping a country
bride gets big-city glam for her big day
know just cuz I'm a drag queen doesn't
mean I'm gonna make Emily look like what
one two three
oh I look gorgeous the episode first air
this is special last year called drag me
down the aisle and it was a runaway
success we also had a lot of people come
to our dance instagrams in social media
my favorite was somebody said I'm gonna
get divorced so I can get married yeah I
remember like why not its track
[Laughter]
[Music]